lucifer
phosphorus ishtar morningstar evening
star all these sonorous names signify
one of the same celestial body
venus the third brightest object in our
sky this planet has always attracted sky
watches and scientists
for many years dense impenetrable clouds
shrouding its surface have excited
observer's imagination which prompted
ideas of now a boundless ocean with
impossible jungles crawling with
monsters the reality turned out to be
even more complicated and horrifying
than these naive assumptions
so what does venus really conceal from
us
[Music]
cosmo
venus is the sun's second closest planet
lying .72 astronomical units away from
the system's center its orbital period
equals roughly 225
earth days
interestingly every 584 days the
distance between venus and our planet
shrinks to its smallest at approximately
0.25 astronomical units
notably venus faces the earth with one
on the same side throughout their
closest approach there is no hard
evidence to account for this fact but it
may be either due to the tidal forces
exerted by our planet or else it could
be a mere coincidence
in terms of its physical characteristics
venus resembles the earth in many ways
its average radius equals
6052 kilometers or 95 percent that of
the earth and its mass is 4.87 times 10
to the power of 24 kilograms which is
0.82 that of our planet
every
243 days venus completes a full rotation
on its axis and the rotation axis is
tilted at 3.4 degrees with respect to
the ecliptic plane
for a long time venus has concealed its
real face from observers on the earth
behind a veil of its dense atmosphere
and thick clouds
this gave rise to a whole plethora of
highly imaginative hypotheses and
assumptions some of them claimed that
there was a highly advanced civilization
concealed under the planet's impervious
outer layer while others suggested that
there was a world that was home to
peculiar life forms
until a certain point in the recent past
assumptions about venus were to be
confined to the realms of fancy
space flights and the advancement of
radio location technologies proved to be
a major breakthrough that made the
desired dances closer than ever
for example it turned out that radio
waves of a certain range pass freely
through the planet's atmosphere and get
reflected from solid rocks
this effect made it possible to make the
first maps of venus back in 1978 by the
orbiter pioneer venus 1. soviet orbiters
contributed to the collected data but
the maps were accurate up to one to two
kilometers and outlined only the largest
features of the venusian terrain this is
the reason why it was necessary to go on
to send the magellan orbiter a large
specialized radar
in the period from 1990 to 1994
images of 95 of the planet's surface
were beamed back to the earth by the
spacecraft
interestingly their resolution reached
120 meters
the information collected by the
magellan spacecraft is still considered
the most exhaustive and accurate data
about the venusian surface
before talking about any planet's
surface it's worth looking at its inner
makeup
according to the most reliable and
well-grounded theory venus has a
metallic core at its center whose mass
accounts for as much as 25 of the
planet's overall mass observations show
that venus has no magnetic field which
is why the metallic core is more likely
than not in a solid state
it is embedded in a silicate mantle as
deep as three thousand kilometers
its upper layer is a solid crust whose
average thickness measures as much as 16
kilometers
it is posited that venus's lithosphere
doesn't form tectonic plates on account
of high temperatures and a high
viscosity of the rocks this makes the
planet's geologic activity quite
different from that on our earth
venus is also peculiar for not having
that many large impact craters
large areas of its surface are covered
by basalt plains that formed from
solidified lava
some features of the relief found here
are uniquely venusian and are not to be
found on any other planet in the solar
system
an example of these is tessary highly
ragged mountainous areas resembling roof
tiles
arachnoids and caroni are two other
unique types of the planet's terrain
round aroval structures with diameters
measuring several hundred kilometers
they appear to be impact craters but
their origin is different rather than
celestial objects info
they formed as a result of tectonic
processes
an unprepared viewer will not easily
notice any features of the venusian
terrain even in processed images that's
why let's take a look at the elevation
map of the planet's surface where areas
of different height are marked by
contrast colours
the region that instantly catches our
eye is the largest elevated feature on
venus nicknamed aphrodite terra
areas like that may well be considered
conditional continents of the planet
aphrodite terra is a gigantic territory
stretching along the planet's equator
its mountainous relief is rather
elaborate according to different
estimates the length of aphrodite terror
may reach 18 000 kilometers and the
width around 5000 kilometers
depending on the method of defining the
continent's borders its area is
estimated in the range from 29 to 41
million square kilometers which is
comparable with the area of asia
if we look at aphrodite terror we will
see three vast areas
artla reggio
thetis reggio and davdo reggio
the first one of these is located in the
eastern part of the continent and is
notable for the highest volcano on venus
mart mons
the distance from its foot to its peak
measures around 5 kilometers and the
overall height above the average level
of the celestial object's surface is
anything from 8.3 to 8.8 kilometers
according to different estimates
the volcano is currently dormant
although there is evidence that it
erupted comparatively recently in
geological terms namely it can be
inferred both from solidified lava flows
and lack of impact craters on the
volcano's slopes
of the reggio sprawls in the western
part of aphrodite terra
this is a region particularly attractive
in terms of tectonic processes
the mountain ridges here run in
different directions which means that
there are several forces tearing at the
crust simultaneously and deforming it
moreover deep crevices have been
discovered here that contain traces of
lava spillage
these may well be considered the most
bizarre volcanoes on the planet
we're moving on to the west to the very
edge of the continent where the alleged
descent points of four venera probes can
be found and two of the probes were
destroyed by the planet's atmosphere
before reaching the surface
all these are located in the southern
part of a vast lowland region known as
guinevere planitia
it stretches for many thousands of
kilometers and is quite a match to
aphrodite terror in terms of area
even though it is called a planitia
the area has an elaborate relief which
is a mixture of various geologic
formations
it is thought that the planet's crust
was being crumpled by tectonic forces
for many hundreds of millions of years
and this produced the ridges and the
folds at the same time the lava spilling
from the crevices spread across and
solidified filling the lowlands with
smooth basaud plains
as a result this region is rich in both
flat areas and clearly defined uplands
the western part of guinevere planitia
borders on the so-called beta regio
as this vast area looks quite bright in
photos it is one of the first features
of venusian relief that got its own name
beta reggio is an elevated area which is
more or less round shaped with a
diameter measuring roughly two and a
half thousand kilometers its eastern
part is the final abode of the debris of
the spacecraft venera 9 and venera 10
the spacecraft which beamed back to us
the first ever photos of venus back in
1975.
they also gauged the atmosphere's
parameters and sampled the soil which
turned out to be similar to basalts back
on the earth
all this information allows us to assume
that beta reggio is the largest volcanic
massif on venus
that is why this area offers highest
chances to discover active volcanoes on
the planet
we're moving on to the north now to the
second largest conditional venusian
continent dubbed ishtar terra
it stretches for roughly eight thousand
kilometers east to west and
approximately two and a half thousand
kilometers north to south
the territories area equals about eight
and a half million square kilometers
which makes ishtar terra only slightly
larger than australia
in the center is the largest volcanic
massif on venus
maxwell montes
they tower 11 kilometers high above the
planet's average level and seven
kilometers above the rest of the relief
around
the highest peak in the center of the
region is a comparatively flat plateau
measuring roughly 200 by 400 kilometers
the difference in height doesn't exceed
one and a half kilometers so it is
extremely difficult to distinguish
separate peaks as the measurements are
not accurate enough
maxwell montes are the coldest region on
the planet
the temperature here is as low as around
380 degrees celsius and the atmosphere
is about twice as rarefied as near the
surface
still it is 44 times denser than that of
the earth
another thing about this region is that
it looks quite bright in photos which
means that the surface of the peaks and
slopes is likely to be covered with some
substance which reflects radio waves
remarkably well
it is thought that it could be metallic
compounds with impurities of sulfur like
pyrite hematite or galena exposed to
high temperatures these substances can
vaporize from the surfaces of lowlands
and then precipitate in colder
mountainous regions as fine grain
reminiscent of snow
while examining the venusian surface you
can't help thinking this
are all these amazing and mysterious
places to remain unexplored by humans
is there a chance of us ever leaving our
footprints on this planet's surface
so close yet so forbidding
because the atmospheric pressure on
venus is about 93 times that of the
earth and the temperature near the
planet's surface is on average
737 kelvin or
464 degrees celsius
these conditions are so extreme that
even space probes especially designed to
explore venus last no more than an hour
as for terraforming venus this idea
seems totally unrealistic
on the other hand
there are in venus's atmosphere some
layers whose temperature and pressure
are close to those of the earth in the
last century ideas were even put forward
about designing a habitable base
hovering in the planet's atmosphere
suspended from special aerostats still
in reality the actual possibility of
putting such projects into practice
remains an open question
and either way
venus is awaiting her heroes and her
secrets will sooner or later be revealed
dear friends of course it is impossible
to cover a global topic like that
profoundly within just one episode there
is quite a number of exciting facts we
haven't spoken about and if you'd like
to find out more feel free to let us
know in the comments if you enjoyed the
video we'll be happy if you give us a
like
and let's keep in touch
you